ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi stiamo per fare uno
dei piatti se non è il piatto al quale
sono più legato in assoluto nella storia
dei piatti ai quali sono legato la pasta
alla norma di mia nonna
si dice che l'importanza di un luogo sia
data dalle persone con le quali
condividi questo luogo ecco per me la
sicilia e in particolare l'estate in
sicilia è sinonimo di famiglia e la
famiglia per me è sinonimo di magna noi
a casa specialmente d'estate quando ci
finiamo tutti quanti insieme
mangiamo da fare schifo è uno dei piatti
che amo di più è che li conducono sempre
a questo ricordo che ogni estate vado a
cercare è proprio la norma vediamo
subito di cosa avremmo bisogno per farla
ma non per farne una qualsiasi ribadisco
per fare quella che mangiamo noi per
fare la pasta alla norma come la
famiglia nonna avremo bisogno di
melanzane pomodori freschi basilico che
io continuo a dire perché perché perché
perché perché che tocca ne abbiamo una
piantina di basilico che sta morirà voi
la perché continua a portarmi alla
cucina perché io tutti quanti scrivetelo
qua sotto addio jennifer impasta io in
questo caso utilizzo l'ha colta mai
parleremo dopo detto chi utilizzi la
corta a job cattura non è vero e olio
sale e soprattutto ricotta salata non io
non è il mio né ricotta salata per prima
cosa perché il pomodoro lo tagliamo ho
deciso che mi pesava questo qui quindi
in realtà solo però che faranno tac tac
ultimo dormire quando continuano sempre
a tagliarlo a mano a ultimo taglio hai
massacrato un pochino gli ho fatto un po
di un bacio per la tua cerico posso
baciarlo l'aglio quanto tagliato le
schiaccio no io non taglio niente fiata
fiata pura dicevo prendiamo l'aglio
intero e lo schiacciamo mi raccomando
ragazzi vanno utilizzati gli ingredienti
in cucina dovete essere super dedicati
perfetto mettiamo dentro a questo punto
basilico 1234567 è a questo punto dopo
averlo sciacquato lo aggiungeremo
all'interno del nostro piatto
prendiamo il miur faccio preferito la
melanzana simba mufasa no allora questo
sarà motivo di diatribe perché noi la
melanzana non la facciamo come vorrebbe
la tradizione cioè tutta quanta tagliata
a fettine che poi dovreste infilare
inter e della pasta e poi aiutarti a
piacimento ma la facciamo a quadrettoni
abelli spero perché fette alte così 1 2
3 1 comunque bisogna dire che in
famiglia la facciamo in entrambi monia è
vero ma quando siamo in 200 noi facciamo
così perché sennò ci ammazziamo per
tenderci quelle melanzane e l'ultimo gli
ultimi tre team angolo prendersene pasta
al sugo mette il primo cda melanzane e
basta
le porte dettaglio la melanzana mi ha
detto poi ricomporle vedere se riesco a
fare i cubi senza lo sta ritagliando un
palazzo alla fine vi ritroverete con una
cosa così io credo di aver leggermente
esagerato con due melanzane ci sono più
chicchi di melanzane che devasta questa
qui è la tradizione nostra bambina avere
sempre l'ansa che possono venire 12
persone all'improvviso adesso dovremo
scolare le melanzane
come si fa a scolare le melanzane mi
direte voi che vuol dire scolari
melanzane dovremmo prendere del sale e
metterlo ovunque in modo da far tirare
fuori l'acqua e allo stesso tempo quando
non so perfettamente di stagione e
togliere anche la mano strato di
melanzane se le fate a fettine
mettete direttamente la melanzana a
fettine io faccio così a questo punto ci
butto sopra del sale altro stradino di
melanzane e di nuovo una diavoleria
della nostra terra
e anche in questo caso ultimo strato io
sto usando la friggitrice a casa nostra
usano lo scolapasta poi aspetteremo una
mezz'oretta il tempo veramente di fare
il sugo e tenete inizieranno a colare
questi sono i miei anni lui nel loro
salvatore purtroppo non c'è più e lei
invece mia nonna che è un po cambiata
nel tempo ma per me rimane sempre così
perché secondo me non mi sono sempre
come erano quando erano giovani e per
conto mio teorie di vita mia nonna è
sempre stata una classica donna che ti
dice lanciano niente da mangiare che poi
preparati da un pranzo per 14 e continua
a essere così continua a essere la
regina il fritto e la regina della norma
quindi non potete dire niente anche se
siete autoctoni non potete dirmi niente
su questa basta il sugo è fatto un
pochino sbollentato le bucce si sono
separate quindi quando dovevo fare è
prendere il quale si chiama balla
vendere passaverdure in modo da separare
semi bucce tutto quanto dalla polpa che
poi metteremo sulla padella per far
addensare sta per escludere però come te
lo sono scordato
ma sono scordato però ci sono delle
alternative hai un'idea già mi ho un
idea di coinvolgere va bene ma bella che
aveva eliminato gli anche i semi per
favore non ci credo anzi no un idea ma
non coinvolge più terme romane
abbiamo tolto laglio ma ragazzi
amen passiamo tutto quanto un minipimer
anche basilico diga guardate il
risultato ottenuto pazzesco guardate
questi pezzetti il basilico quello
piccolo buonissimi aggiustiamo di sale
zucchero un cucchiaio anche se la metto
un pochino di più perché mi piace
particolarmente dolce la passata e poi
l'olio lo metteremo solo alla fine a
crudo e chaka khan akela kaa finché non
sarà perfetto copriamo con un
paraschizzi e passiamo alle melanzane
uso la pregi tricea casa in realtà
utilizzano tutti quanti una bella
padella e ogni volta rimboccano con
l'olio come più facile così quindi ovvio
la frittura è un'altra cosa
ma voi avete la friggitrice d'aria a
casa come vi ci trovate se ce l'avete
perché sto tipo conigli per comprarla
perché la vendono benissimo devo capire
però da chi la usa davvero severamente
pica
ma intanto per lo yemen temperatura e
procedere una cosa ecco fradicia quindi
adesso dovremo travasare all'interno di
una ciotola con dello scottex e pian
piano principale momento soft porno o
che ci ha ripensato a questa cosa
inutile veri già sommerse a posto io vi
invito un attimo a sentire questa cosa
qui perché per me è rumore di estate a
catania
il suo è pronto guardate come ci sono de
simini se qualcuno avesse portato magari
il passaverdure non ci sarebbe stato
questo problema ma ora che è pronto olio
a crudo dentro a questa brocca ce n'è
uno toscano buonissimo e io appunto
ragazzi chimica non lo sono
commovente comunque mettiamo subito
l'acqua sulla patta sulla pasta l'acqua
per la pasta sul fuoco che iniziamo a
farla bollire visto che delle melanzane
sono lì lì per essere fatte
mi raccomando il coperchio perché così
vuole prima acqua così posso capirlo
yeah vedranno col debutto del il suo
bolle le melanzane stato trincee pronto
le melanzane stanno affliggendo e
l'acqua bolle che togliamo le ultime
melanzane veloce veloce alvoro
componiamo tutto quanto su gol mi aiuto
con un legamento le buttiamo dentro la
maggior parte le melanzane ma se
vogliamo fare i figli li lasciano fuori
si raggiunge possa fare il movimento di
polso vermante carla intento a nora il
salto sì il salto scusa 22 di come gira
il south gianni vietiamo grattugiata di
ricotta salata
allora questo qui è il piatto finale può
insomma non secondo far vedere che cosa
è la vita è pazzesco se volete leggere
tutti quanti gli ingredienti
procedimenti abbiamo scritto un articolo
perdonando breve potete trovare il link
qua sotto dell'info box iscrivetevi
inoltre a questo canale metteteci un bel
pollice in su per il e fatemi sapere
qual è per voi il piatto che rappresenta
nostra
miglio che sono curioso detto ciò un
ospite speciale questo momento che mia
mamma ma migliora affatto 200.000 volte
questa pasta si l'ho fatto tante volte
anche se l'esperienza che ne dalla nonna
anzi dal bisnonno poi diciamo quella che
leggiamo la marcia inglese
la mamma di gianni però la sapete fare
tronisti comunque scusate che lo
stendino dietro ai ragazzi questo si fa
sempre più grande così pronta per la
santissima dai ragazzi fateci sognare
sto morendo di profumo di mamma e sulle
melanzane suo bacione volte se ne erano
nè senza prima che io ringrazio in
cucina non ci credo lupo vergogna del
tutto e mangia raggio ci vediamo martedì
prossimo ciao mamma sono anche tu un
profumo d'estate festival proprio
famiglia tutti insieme tutti insieme
famiglia al basilico
lancio un gioco e tocco in più con
quella fase sembrano magnani